[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce sens public 90 minutes pour
donner du sens à l'actualité et vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
crises que nous traversons voici le
sommaire de ce 16 novembre l'actualité
pour commencer et ce missiles qui a fait
deux morts hier soir dans un village
polonais proche de la frontière
ukrainienne la Pologne pays membres de
l'OTAN le risque d'escalade était réel
mais les chefs d'états réunis au G20 ont
envie de pointer un dommage collatéral
un tir de défense face à l'attaque russe
visant les installations électriques de
l'Ukraine on décode ces dernières 24
heures avec nos experts dans une minute
et puis dans notre second débat
volontairement décalé vous le savez de
l'actualité du jour on revient sur ses
actions de militants écologistes
radicaux des toiles de maître asperger
de soupe et des violences contre les
gendarmes à Sainte-Soline condamnés par
le Président de la République
je pense que la radicalité politique
l'impatience la force la volonté de
faire ne justifie jamais le non-respect
d'autrui de son intégrité physique et
des règles pour vivre en société
même si c'est légitime faut-il pour
autant parler d'éco-terrorisme comme
Gérald Darmanin face à l'urgence
climatique la violence est-elle
indispensable ou contre-productif
réponse dans 45 minutes mais d'abord un
village polonais le centre de
l'attention mondiale et cette question
brûlante qui a tiré celui-ci meurtrier
Sandra Cerqueira
c'est une attaque qui aurait pu faire
rentrer les pays de l'OTAN dans la
guerre contre la Russie une violente
explosion sur le territoire polonais
membre de l'OTAN qui a fait deux morts
dans une exploitation agricole dans un
village à moins de 10 km de la frontière
avec l'Ukraine un peu plus tôt dans la
journée russe et ukrainien se sont
renvoyés la balle sur la responsabilité
de ses frappes mais rapidement la piste
russe a été écartée l'OTAN affirme que
la Russie porte la responsabilité de ce
qui s'est passé en Pologne car c'est le
résultat direct de la vague d'attaque de
Moscou hier contre l'Ukraine selon le
chef de l'OTAN rien n'indique qu'il y
ait une attaque délibérée contre la
Pologne le missile proviendrait de la
défense ukrainienne autre analyse
préliminaire suggère que l'incident a
probablement été causé par un missile de
défense aérienne ukrainien tiré pour
défendre le territoire ukrainien contre
les attaques russes lors d'une réunion
du Conseil de sécurité nationale le
président polonais a confirmé la thèse
de l'accident
rien n'indique qu'il s'agissait d'une
attaque intentionnelle contre la Pologne
il s'agit probablement d'un accident
malheureux le risque d'escalade a ainsi
été rapidement évité c'est un scénario
redouté depuis le 24 février Emmanuel
Macron a affirmé que le G20 ne veut pas
de la guerre en Ukraine et même si le
président Poutine n'était pas venu le
message que lui envoie les plus grandes
puissances économiques du monde réunis à
Bali et très clair la grande majorité
des membres du G20 condamne
explicitement la guerre en Ukraine
c'est un fait nous l'avons constaté à
l'ONU lors du vote de la dernière
résolution et le G20 en prend acte en
marge du G20 Emmanuel Macron a appelé la
Chine à devenir un médiateur dans le
conflit entretien et Moscou voilà
24 heures avec cette question le conflit
petit s'étendre et je vous présente tout
de suite mes invités Dominique trinquant
ancien chef de la mission militaire
française auprès de l'ONU bonsoir
bienvenue à vous Irina mitrychin bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes maître de conférence
à l'INALCO responsable des études de
ukrainiennes Julien Theron bonsoir
bienvenue politique spécialiste en
conflit et sécurité international vous
êtes enseignant à Sciences Po Paris et
coeur avec Isabelle mandro de ce livre
Poutine la stratégie du désordre jusqu'à
la guerre qui est publié aux éditions
tallendier Laetitia cruppa éditorialise
politique est à mes côtés bonsoir
Laetitia j'ai un train quand dans un cas
comme celui-là on va on va un peu voilà
remonter le le temps quels moyens
permettent de savoir avoir assez vite
d'où vient ce missile alors il y a
plusieurs moyens le premier on a vu que
les Polonais ont réagi assez rapidement
ils sont sur le terrain ils sont
capables de voir quel est les débris de
missiles qui a là d'identifier et de
pouvoir dire ce que c'est ils ont
semblent-ils très rapidement dit que
c'était un missile S300 ici laisse 300
je rappelle c'est un missile solaire de
fabrication soviétique russe
et compte tenu de la portée de ce type
de missile ça ne pouvait pas être un
missile envoyé par les Russes donc ça
tombe naturellement sur les Ukrainiens
qui utilisent ce type de missile ça
c'est la première façon de le voir qui
est très sensible c'est très rapide sur
le terrain on va regarder alors il y a
d'autres moyens qui permettent des
moyens
des moins satellitaires qui permettent
d'identifier les tirs qui partent de
droite et de gauche cette zone est
particulière évidemment c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire nous sommes dans une
zone de tension majeure dans il faut
faire très attention à tout ce qui se
passe mais dans le deuxième cas que ce
soit des systèmes radars ou des systèmes
optiques il faut faire un peu du tri
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de monde qui
regardent la zone les Américains en
particulier sont très attentifs et ont
beaucoup de moyens il faut faire un peu
de tri donc il faut laisser un peu de
temps pour que ces deux enquêtes entre
guillemets qu'elles soient sur le
terrain qu'elles soient ailleurs
puissent déboucher sur une conclusion et
on va évidemment analyser la
communication du Président ukrainien
dans un instant avec Laetitia Irina
mitrychin le fait que ce soit a priori
on va rester un tout petit peu prudent à
missile ukrainien ça permet d'éviter
l'escalade on y reviendra aussi est-ce
qu'il y avait vraiment un risque
d'escalade ou pas mais on a quand même
senti une forme de soulagement de la
communauté internationale dans ces
dernières 24 heures oui et les
Ukrainiens en ont conçu une certaine
amertume en disant voilà mais tant que
ce sont les Ukrainiens tant que ce sont
des centaines des milliers d'Ukrainiens
qui sont des victimes bon ça reste à
l'Ukraine et on a on est soulagé parce
que ça pas toucher le territoire d'un
pays de l'OTAN ou un pays de l'Union
européenne en même temps les économies
sont parfaitement conscients des enjeux
et de la situation et ils comprennent
parfaitement que c'est une guerre que se
déroule sur le territoire et si en plus
c'est un missile donc un tirax un
missile qui est qui a été lancé pour
intercepter donc un missile russe qui a
causé ce dommage je pense que le
président Zelinski après avoir présenté
ces
condoléances fera sans doute une sortie
plus plus
appuyé sur sur ce fait sur cette
responsabilité oui oui et puis on attend
enfin voilà pour l'instant il y a eu un
communiqué de diverski je pense qu'il y
a une prise de de parole nouvelle prise
de parole je veux bien qu'on me la
confirme en régie qui qui ne saurait
tarder donc on vous la donnera
évidemment en direct Julien te rend le
mot du jour c'était prudent même les
Polonais non pas sur réagi on peut dire
ça oui en fait si on compare à d'autres
accidents si je puis dire de belligérant
c'est à dire des éléments qui débordent
du cadre volontairement ou pas on
pourrait comparer ça à l'armée syrienne
par exemple l'armée arabe syrienne donc
les forces probachard qui en fait ont
bombardé le territoire Arthur que
c'était il y a quelques années en Syrie
et on avait déjà craint effectivement un
accrochage avec l'OTAN de la part de
l'armée arabe syrienne puisque la
Turquie fait partie de l'OTAN donc c'est
un autre épisode où on s'était déjà
demandé si l'OTAN n'était pas déjà entré
en guerre vers des forces avec un peu
les mêmes questions est-ce que l'armée
arabe syrienne peut être battue est-ce
que il y avait vraiment un risque
d'escalade est-ce que ça concernait
juste la Turquie comme là la Pologne ou
l'ensemble de l'OTAN en réalité
l'article 5 qui serait la clause de
solidarité de l'OTAN n'a été déclenchée
qu'une seule fois au moment du 11
septembre et ça a mis un mois à être
déclenché donc aujourd'hui on a revu un
peu de ces process mais fondamentalement
on n'était pas nécessairement au bord
d'un conflit mondial c'est intéressant
on y reviendra évidemment un peu en
détail dans la procédure de l'OTAN et ce
qui est ce qui pourrait se passer mais
donc je effectivement j'avais
l'information qu'il y avait une nouvelle
réaction de du président ukrainien alors
c'est très bref puisque c'est l'agence
France pas ce qui nous le dit en
quelques mots le missile tombait en
Pologne était russe citation de volody
mirzuelinski cité par des médias donc
pour l'instant il y a pas de démenti
ukrainien alors Laetitia va juste un mot
Alexis Danny Love qui est le secrétaire
du Conseil national
ukrainien a maintenu effectivement qu'il
avait des preuves
russe c'est le terme qui a été employé
ultra alors on va on va analyser
justement à la fois cette communication
de ski et puis la réaction de du G20
Laetitia qui a joué la carte de
l'apaisement avec un mot d'ordre c'était
la désescalade oui parce que très vite
dans la nuit les services américains
alors les Polonais d'abord mais les
services américains ont dit
qu'effectivement il y avait fort peu de
probabilité pour que celui-ci soit tiré
depuis la Russie vers la Pologne ce qui
aurait été une attaque frontale un amant
de l'OTAN comme on l'a dit et peut-être
aurait pu enclencher un tournant dans
cette guerre deux ans en plus que le
président
ukrainien Thomas a communiqué par
visio-conférence avec des mots très
forts en accusant la Russie je vous
propose de l'écouter
russe ont frappés hier le territoire de
la Pologne voisine il doit y avoir une
réaction rapide cette attaque de
missiles est un vrai message de la
Russie adressé au G20 donc quand je dis
j'ai 19 je me trompe pas parce que la
Russie est un état terroriste et nous
nous défendons contre elle et c'est
peut-être selon moi une des premières
fautes de communication qu'il maîtrise
parfaitement magistralement du président
ukrainien alors pourquoi c'est une faute
de communication parce que cette
déclaration vient heurter de plein fouet
le texte final du G20 Thomas qui
condamne la guerre on l'a entendu à
Emmanuel Macron a déclenché par la
Russie et que même les Russes ont signé
et d'ailleurs la France aurait été
vraiment à la manœuvre pour que ce texte
soit aussi dur or le message Zelinski
occulte finalement ce travail d'autant
que tous les membres on l'a entendu
aussi semblent unanime sur le fait que
normalement l'hypothèse qui est
privilégiée pour le moment c'est que ce
missile proviendrait effectivement du
crâne alors il y avait un enjeu qui
était fort ne pas affaiblir volo
diversinski avec un G20 qui le soutient
là aussi on verra que les mots ont été
choisis au trébuchet pour en premier une
très vieille expression exactement et
c'est ce qui a tenté de faire Emmanuel
Macron dans sa conférence de presse
juste avant de s'envoler pour Bangkok
écouter
il y a eu hier une journée terrible pour
l'Ukraine et le peuple ukrainien
il y a eu plus de 85 missiles qui sont
tombés sur le sol ukrainien sur des
cibles je le rappelle ici civil
c'est-à-dire des personnes des
infrastructures civiles et donc oui
c'est un message très clair et comme
souvent à chaque fois qu'il y a un recul
militaire sur le terrain il y a eu une
offensive aérienne redoublée de la part
de la Russie et donc la journée d'hier
fut une journée terrible pour l'Ukraine
et le peuple ukrainien
dans ce contexte il y a eu ces deux
missiles tombées sur le sol polonais
avec deux victimes et je redis ici notre
solidarité nos condoléances au peuple
polonais
aujourd'hui les circonstances ne
permettent pas d'attribuer ses tirs et
donc je resterai extrêmement prudent
donc je sais pas ce qu'a subi l'Ukraine
et ensuite deux tirs qui sont tombés sur
le sol polonais
c'est très clair si on décortique c'est
un communication deux tiers pour
l'Ukraine pour la journée terrible qui a
vécu l'Ukraine le peuple ukrainien le
soutien de la France et du G20 à
l'Ukraine et puis
factuellement il le met en second plan
ses domicile tomber sur le sol polonais
c'est aussi la teneur du message de
l'OTAN cet après-midi sans doute pour
permettre à volo 2000 Zener ski et vous
le disiez tout à l'heure de préparer une
deuxième communication alors là Thomas
vous nous dites quel aspect il maintient
que ses russes mais en tout cas du côté
du G20 c'était ça la stratégie lui
permettre de communiquer à nouveau et
peut-être pour reculer un peu alors sauf
que le dernier élément effectivement de
cette fin d'après-midi c'est la
confirmation pour l'instant par le
pouvoir ukrainien voilà le missile
tombait en Pologne était russe zenzky
par des médias pour être très précis sur
le la dépêche de l'agence France
Irina mitry-cino la première réaction
c'est de se dire il a parlé trop vite
mais peut-être que finalement il y a
alors la volonté de passer excuser trop
vite non plus ou alors d'en faire une
stratégie comment vous l'analysez ça
alors je pense que tout d'abord il faut
et le président
Macron elle a parfaitement rappelé voir
le contexte dans lequel on a appris ces
cette frappe donc toute cette journée
qui est qui a été synonyme de d'une
attaque terrible de cette pluie de
missile environ une centaine de missiles
qui sont tombés sur l'Ukraine et sur
toute l'Ukraine et sur les
infrastructures civiles causant de
dommages importantes notamment dans dans
tout ce qui est concerne l'électricité
le chauffage etc
dans le noir ensuite quand même le
message était de dire voilà les grands
pays sont réunis pour un G20 et le
message de la Russie le jour même et on
sait que ça c'est déjà produit lors des
grandes visites donc des personnalités
internationales à l'Ukraine il y a eu
ces bombardements et donc c'est c'est
comme une une réponse en fait il a parlé
d'une gifle donnée à la communauté
internationale donc je pense qu'il faut
voir le contexte général dans lequel il
a parlé et puis n'oublions je crois que
c'est un président d'un pays qui est en
guerre depuis un mois qui connaît quand
même des dommages aujourd'hui
extrêmement importantes en prévision de
de l'hiver qui qui s'annonce donc je
pense qu'il a il a il a été peut-être
emporté par l'émotion mais il a été à la
tête de son peuple et je pense qu'il a
il est je doute qui est quelqu'un qui
aurait pu agir autrement dans son alors
actuellement les Ukrainiens d'abord les
ukrainiens et donc c'est l'Occitanie
Love qui vient de préciser demande à
être présent sur le site lors de la vie
est possible dans ce pays offert le tout
le concours pour mettre toutes les
lumières sur sur ce qui s'est passé donc
les éléments à la hauteur les Ukrainiens
à la hauteur des éléments dont tu
disposes estiment que pour l'instant
rien ne permet d'incriminer les
Ukrainiens maintenant est-ce que si
c'est une façon de s'enferrer alors
qu'il y a alors que l'épreuve
s'accumulent je pense que c'est une
mauvaise stratégie on le verra assez
vite les prochaines heures devraient
nous permet d'avancer ce qui est
intéressant de mettre un camp c'est on a
calculé entre le la chute du démiciles
et la première réaction du président
Zelinski il se passe 5h20
est-ce que au bout de 5h20 il a il
manque d'informations ou alors il a
suffisamment d'informations
le premier point je pense qu'il y a des
circonstances atténuantes si j'ose dire
pour le président de l'instit d'abord il
fait la guerre depuis 9 mois et sur le
front depuis 9 mois on comprend bon la
journée d'hier a été particulièrement
pénible a été difficile donc
circonstances atténuantes deuxième point
c'est un homme des médias et là il a
pris la vague des médias en fait et il a
abondé sur on n'attend pas d'avoir des
confirmations et on regarde ça troisième
point vous parliez de solidarité avec
l'Ukraine mais moi je parle aussi de
solidarité de l'Ukraine avec tous les
gens qui au j'ai faim se débrouillent
pour avoir la citation que nous avons eu
qui est un soutien à l'Ukraine qui est
une condamnation de la Russie et donc
moi j'avoue que je suis un peu déçu que
il ne réalise pas que tout le monde le
soutient mais il faut que lui reste
solidaire aussi de ce qu'ils soutiennent
sinon il va y avoir un problème au bout
d'un moment on fait très référence au
communiqué commun du G20 on peut le voir
c'est vraiment le CC peut-être un peu
alambicat à mon avis mais bon on peut le
comprendre parce que autour de la table
il y a les États-Unis la France la Chine
la Turquie entre autres enfin voilà il
faut quand même trouver des mots communs
pour tous ces pays dénominateur commun
c'est toujours la plupart la plupart des
membres du G20 a condamné fermement la
guerre en Ukraine et tous se sont
accordés sur le fait que le conflit sape
l'économie mondiale voilà les les les
termes qui ont été choisis comme vous
dites plus petit dénominateur commun à
l'évidence la Russie ne pouvait pas
condamner la Russie ça donc ça fait
partie des gens qui ont dû dire moi je
signe pas ça en revanche que ça
s'appelait l'économie mondiale tous donc
il y avait la Russie là dedans donc
mais je ce que ce que je veux dire c'est
que beaucoup de pays font des efforts
énormes pour soutenir la l'Ukraine dans
le combat face à l'invasion russe mais
le président zeninski peut pas être tout
seul en tête comme ça sans tenir compte
de la position des autres il doit tenir
compte bien sûr qu'il défend son peuple
mais il doit tenir compte de la position
des autres sinon la cohésion va se
casser alors c'est bon Julien Theron
est-ce que cette séquence cette dernière
24 heures qu'on est en train de
d'analyser
fragilise quand même un petit peu volody
myrski après vous
je suis pas forcément en ligne avec ce
qui vient d'être dit parce que je vois
pas forcément où est le manque de
solidarité vis-à-vis des autres chefs
d'État ce que je pense c'est que il doit
certainement être convaincu d'avoir des
éléments de preuve du fait que c'est un
missile russe on ne lui connaît pas
d'erreur volontaire et depuis en avant
dans un mensonge ça n'a pas été
répertorié dans aucun de ces discours
surtout si c'est quand même soutenu par
le renseignement militaire
ukrainien alors ça ne veut pas dire
forcément que c'est vrai moi je ne le
sais pas personne ne le sait autour
d'admirable
il y a des équipes polonaises et
américaines qui sont en train d'enquêter
sur place pas ukrainien en l'occurrence
ils ont pas encore eu l'autorisation de
se rendre sur le site mais
moi ce que je pense c'est que peut-être
qu'il a des éléments d'information qui
sont peut-être vrai à ce moment là on va
pas trop se lancer qui sont peut-être
faux également
non pas nécessairement vu que c'est sur
le pays sur lequel aurait été tiré le
missile et que c'est le pays qu'aurait
lancé le missile dont je vois pas
pourquoi ce serait parti en surprenant
qu'ils aient des aimants d'information
spécifique mais moi je n'en sais rien ce
que je dis c'est que je pense que là il
est pas forcément dans une tentative de
manipulation qui serait voué à l'échec
évidemment parce qu'elles américains
comme vous les indiquez qui ont des
moyens de renseignement absolument
considérables donc ce serait
complètement idiot et on ne lui connaît
pas de geste aussi aussi
idiot dans ce dans ce dans ce sens là en
revanche effectivement peut-être qu'il a
des éléments d'information qui sont pas
avérés ou qui sont avérés et ça
l'enquête le dira alors jouer on va
revenir sur sur ce missile et je vous
propose d'écouter on disait que la
Pologne avait été prudente et jouer
assez rapidement l'apaisement propose un
extrait de la réaction du président
polonais André Juda qui donne des
détails sur le missile meurtrier que
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
cela montre qu'il s'agissait bien d'un
missile probablement un S300 de
production
fabriquer en Union soviétique donc un
vieux missile il n'y a aucune preuve
qu'il ait été lancé par la Russie
on est donc dans l'hypothèse qui est
pour l'instant le plus communément admis
par la communauté internationale
c'est-à-dire un tir de défense
ukrainien face à la pluie de missilorus
qui s'abattait sur sur l'Ukraine dans
cette journée en entendant le président
polonais je me suis est-ce que c'est pas
étonnant de voir l'armée ukrainienne
tirée un vieux missile soviétique après
9 mois de guerre on pourrait imaginer
que ces stocks là ils les ont utilisés
au début quand ils avaient pas encore
touché les armes occidentales ça c'est
ça a été ma réflexion de non militaires
donc peut-être que vous me dites ça va
pas de sens mais bien vous entendre
parler de l'armement occidentale
permettez-moi de vous dire que les trois
quarts de l'armement
occidentale a été fourni par les pays
autrefois membre du pack de Varsovie et
c'était des armements qu'ils avaient en
stock et qui étaient des armements
soviétiques en particulier le S300
missile anti-aérien d'anciennes
générations donc ça me surprend pas donc
ça déjà
de l'Allemagne Aix de l'Est etc donc ça
ne me surprend absolument pas ok donc
et le fait que les Polonais le disent
tout de suite ça veut dire quoi un S300
c'est un missile anti-aérien avec une
portée quand même limitée or il n'y a
pas de batterie de missiles anti-aériens
russes qui soit dans le rayon d'action
de la chute donc c'est pour ça que leur
conclusion est assez rapide c'est pour
ça que on peut se poser la question
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les termes
employés par le président zenki c'est
une arme il aurait dû rajouter de
fabrication russe parce que russe ça
veut dire ça provient d'une batterie
russe de fabrication russe c'est une
évidence
tout le monde le sait donc voilà où est
la difficulté et pardonnez-moi de
revenir un petit peu et Dieu sait si
j'admire le chef qui est le président
mais il y a des moments où il devient
trop médiatique pour pardonner moi de
contredire un petit peu je me souviens
très très bien de l'offensive sur les
échange ou le gouverneur disait on peut
pas tenir il faut qu'on décroche il
recevait un coup de fil dans la nuit et
le lendemain le gouverneur disait on va
tout reprendre en 48 heures donc tout le
monde savait que c'était totalement
impossible et ils ont fini par décrocher
donc c'est là où si vous voulez la
guerre médiatique et la guerre c'est pas
exactement la même chose et il y a des
moments où il faut faire attention quand
on fait trop de médias pour pouvoir
parce qu'on perd un peu de crédibilité
on perd un peu de crédibilité moi quand
vous annoncez quelque chose comme vous
le dites tout le monde dit les Polonais
les premiers qui sont sur le terrain
alors moi j'espère en revanche qu'ils
vont autoriser les Ukrainiens à venir
parce que ça c'est important que les
Ukrainiens viennent invité à venir voir
parce que c'est la guerre qui se passe
sur leur pays venir voir constater et
pouvoir
polonais donc c'est la Pologne qui peut
très bien dire faites les 15 km qui a
franchissez la frontière et puis la
police ou des experts
Ukrainiens il y a beaucoup d'Ukrainiens
qui franchissent la frontière
régulièrement donc et ça serait
intéressant pour les Ukrainiens le
président polonais a mentionné qu'il
faudrait l'accord polonais naturellement
mais également américain dans l'enquête
donc ça veut dire que on sait pas c'est
juste les Polonais qui bloquent ou les
Américains ce sera plutôt une enquête
internationale ça l'est déjà c'est
bilatéral je veux juste mentionner une
chose une arme de fabrication soviétique
comme vous savez c'est cette fabrication
soviétique c'est pas russe et je pense
pas que ce soit juste sa langue et
fourchait en disant c'est un missile
russe ou de fabrication
de cette réaction vous parlez de la
réaction du président polonais on est
bien d'accord absolument moi ce que je
pense c'est que et pas juste préciser
une chose sur ces histoires d'armes
occidentales en fait le S300 a un
avantage que non pas les armes
entièresiennes fournies par les
Occidentaux pendant les 6 premiers mois
de la guerre c'est que c'est une arme
alors à moyenne porter certes par
rapport
au fait qu'il serait tiré de Russie mais
qui est quand même à plus longue portée
que les armes à épaules disons qui
serait tiré sur le sol et du coup il
s'en servent encore effectivement même
si c'est des vieux matériels parce que
les armements qui interviendraient
depuis comme les irrités allemands par
exemple ont été promis il y a six mois
et viennent à peine d'arriver quelques
exemplaires donc en fait il se servent
encore de ce genre de choses je
préciserai aussi que c'était pas
forcément extrêmement évident pour une
raison aussi qui me semble balistique
c'est à dire que je pense que s'il tire
sur un missile ce qui s'est passé
peut-être c'est qu'ils aient raté le
missile qu'ils aient touché le missile
et qui est une course un petit peu je
sais pas si vous souvenez de cette route
autre incident en Syrie où il y avait un
aéronef russe avait été descendu par la
défense entière il y a une turque et en
fait il y a eu un débat balistique assez
similaire on ne savait pas et la chose
est restée un peu en suspente d'ailleurs
de savoir si l'aéronef était en train de
traverser la frontière aller traverser
la frontière s'il avait été abattu d'un
côté ou de l'autre de la frontière ça va
créer un crise diplomatique entre la
Turquie et la Russie ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que effectivement dans ces
histoires balistiques là il y a des
moments en fait où il est compliqué de
savoir ce qu'il est et peut-être que la
trace dont parle monsieur Daniela et
peut-être une tasse balistique justement
d'un missile qui passait par là voilà je
veux juste préciser ces éléments on va
commencer à se pencher sur la la
question de l'OTAN et de la réaction de
de l'OTAN et je vous propose une
réaction celle du Secrétaire général de
l'Organisation du Traité Atlantique Nord
James saltenberg
je vais être clair
ce n'est pas la faute de l'Ukraine
responsabilité car elle poursuit sa
guerre illégale contre l'Ukraine
on va on va peut-être appeler un peu de
de droit international l'Ukraine et
légitime à se défendre c'est une
évidence c'est une lapalissade mais il
faut le dire dans un contexte comme
comme celui-là même si c'est un tir de
venu de l'Ukraine elle est légitime à le
faire elle se défend légitime elle
légale et légal oui bien sûr vous avez
raison c'est légal et je trouve que tous
les acteurs qui ont rappelé cela toutes
les interventions internationales
individuelles ou collective ont toujours
mis en avant cette responsabilité russe
donc il est clair pour tout le monde que
l'arbre ne doit pas cacher la forêt que
s'il n'y avait pas assez de guerre
déclenchée par la Russie et bien ces
deux polonais ou des milliers de
personnes en Ukraine auraient continué
leur existence paisible donc donc
effectivement cette communication m'a
paru extrêmement juste et sans la
déclaration de vos données meilleures et
un skin il n'y aurait pas tous débat
s'il n'avait pas dit tout de suite oui
ce sont les Russes qui est à terroriste
ont attaqué la Pologne il n'y aurait pas
ce débat tout le monde aura été d'accord
pour dire que l'Ukraine a également le
droit de se défendre et que donc c'est
un accident et que c'est un missile qui
a été tiré probablement que du crâne
voyez-vous en fait il vient percuter et
parasiter finalement une communauté
internationale qui est
unanime
la réponse était parfaitement équilibrée
et je pense que tout le monde a compris
tout le monde a mis aussi en avant le
côté des circonstances atténuantes
combien de dire généralement écoutez le
c'est un président à la tête d'un pays
qui depuis 9 mois subit une attaque
terrible et la plus la guerre depuis la
première guerre depuis sur le continent
européen depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale donc on peut on peut comprendre
ça sa situation ensuite est-ce que
est-ce qu'elle a parlé à ordinateur je
pense qu'il a parlé à la hauteur des
éléments dont il dont il disposait
voilà maintenant pour moi ce n'est pas
le cas pardon mais si ce n'est pas le
cas il prend quand même un risque
important que celui d'être accusé
d'avoir manqué la plus importante
d'avoir confirmé ce mensonge or c'est ce
que on peut et on convient effectivement
reprocher avec Poutine depuis le début
de ce conflit en fait il faut quand même
pas mettre
sur le même plan mais c'est pour ça que
je parlais de fragilisation parce que si
effectivement il y a encore une fois on
est prudent à 7h si effectivement c'est
bien un missile de défense tiré par
l'Ukraine et que volodières zenenski a
continué de dire c'est la Russie bon je
pense pas là on pourra commencer à dire
une fois qu'il va dire maintenant pour
moi ce qui compte c'est comment elle va
s'en sortir même si la commis peut-être
hein faut pas on va voir ce comment il
va sortir de cette situation mais je
pense qu'effectivement c'est si brouille
le message général qui est bon ce
missile mais le fautif c'est la Russie
et c'est la Russie qui attaque et ça
tout doit être d'accord là-dessus mais
on a l'impression là qu'après ce tauxu
de 24 heures ou 36 heures on va être là
à dire ouf en fait il y a pas eu la
guerre entre le temps et l'Ukraine donc
tout va bien on continue comme avant
alors que c'est pas ça mais ça je le
message c'est si c'est arrivé c'est bien
parce que les Russes une fois de plus
ont envoyé une volée de missiles sur des
sites comme le disait le président civil
etc et c'est ça le message central donc
moi ce qui me gêne un petit peu
effectivement c'est que cette discussion
sur ce ben ça brouille un peu le ce
message là qui doit être très clair
alors sur l'OTAN je rappelle l'article 5
du Traité de l'Atlantique Nord les
parties conviennent qu'une attaque armée
contre l'une ou plusieurs parties sera
considérée comme une attaque dirigée
contre toutes les parties vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure Julien Theron
alors on va prendre l'autre hypothèse
c'est toujours défendue par volumes
selinski ce missile c'est missile ont
bien été tirés par la Russie
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
imaginons que dans 24 48 heures nos
premières informations soient démenties
Varsovie pourrait demander à l'OTAN une
réunion et de déclencher l'article 5
ce qui induirait un certain nombre
d'observations de la part des
différentes parties mais ce qui pourrait
légalement induire la formation d'une
coalition par exemple avec un certain
nombre d'objectifs militaire
ça n'est pas un ça n'est pas automatique
donc il n'y a pas d'automaticité on
n'est pas directement en guerre
deuxièmement c'est à la demande du pays
troisièmement des observations peuvent
être formulées contrairement la réponse
est adaptée au nécessités ce qui veut
globalement je m'atocritique globalement
rien dire c'est-à-dire où tout dire si
vous voulez c'est à dire que c'est aux
États partis de l'OTAN de décider de la
réponse militaire qui sera apportée à ça
donc vous voyez entre l'espèce de peur
panique qu'on peut avoir en accident
en train de s'étendre là et la réalité
des choses c'est bien différent j'ai
cité deux exemples par rapport à ça je
voudrais quand même préciser une chose
c'est que dans son dernier discours
Vladimir Poutine dans les études de
conflit ce qu'on appelle warstadis on le
sait depuis 2014 parce qu'on l'étudie
mais il nous l'a dit ouvertement la
dernière fois la Russie était en guerre
depuis 2014
contre l'Occident l'Occident c'est
notamment nous donc dans son dernier
discours et ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est très intéressant de voir
nous notre manière comme vous le disiez
oh bah ça va c'est c'était pas vraiment
les Russes qui attaquaient la Pologne
c'est humain
en guerre contre la Russie mais il faut
bien comprendre que du point de vue de
Moscou il y a une guerre qui est opérée
de cette manière ça se voyait moins
avant parce que c'était par des méthodes
qui étaient sous le spectre sous la
limite de la violence avec des
manipulations médiatiques ce genre de
choses mais aujourd'hui il nous le dit
ouvertement et il faut l'entendre il
faut l'entendre Irina mitrychin
peut-être que c'est un peu provocateur
ce que je veux dire mais malgré l'aide
internationale qui est importante qui
est qui est nombreuse il y a un fait
c'est que l'Ukraine se bat seul sur son
sol est-ce qu'elle pourrait espérer que
la guerre gagne ces pays voisins membres
de
ce n'est pas son objectif son objectif
c'est de gagner cette guerre de
récupérer son territoire et de condamner
tous ces tous ces crimes donc d'ailleurs
le président Zelinski dans son discours
devant devant le jugement à proposer un
plan avec les différents points donc les
cherche pas à éteindre le conflit en
revanche il cherche à avoir le maximum
de soutien et à gagner la guerre sur
leur sol j'ai un trinquant est-ce que
ces dernières 24 heures c'est aussi une
sorte de de je donne pas plus
d'importance que ça n'en a mis une sorte
de mini test pour l'OTAN oui je trouve
je suis assez d'accord avec vous et je
trouve que les les gouvernants du
lottant le système du OTAN a montré sa
sagesse sa capacité de réagir mais aussi
sa capacité de prendre la mesure des
choses
sur l'article 5 rien à rajouter de tout
ce qui a été très bien dit j'ajoute
simplement que faut pas oublier qu'il y
a un dispositif défensif de l'OTAN qui
fonctionne actuellement il y a des
avions français qui sont dans le ciel de
Pologne en Estonie donc ce dispositif ça
veut dire aussi que tout le monde veille
et que s'il y avait une escalade il y
aurait des réflexes d'autodéfense
j'allais dire mais que ça veut pas dire
de passer à l'article 5 tout de suite
les reflexes de taux défense c'est si
des avions sont attaqués si on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a une frappe
qu'est-ce qu'on fait mais effectivement
ensuite il faut que le pays le demande
et puis ça n'a rien de automatique bien
sûr d'où la narration
non et puis même plus dans le
déclenchement il y a la réflexion et je
crois que vous avez raison dans les 24
heures on a montré que le temps de
s'emballer pas le temps était capable de
réfléchir de mesurer les conséquences
sur le fond de se dire une attaque
délibérée de la Russie contre le temps
on y croit pas on y croit pas parce que
une attaque délibérée de l'OTAN contre
un pays de l'OTAN donc contre le temps
c'est la fin du régime de Poutine il le
sait il a pas été capable de vaincre
je suis en guerre contre l'Occident on
regarde des différents opinions
publiques occidentales est-ce que tout
le monde suivrait les chefs d'État si un
missile tombait dans un état de l'étang
ça fait partie de nous des hypothèses
sur lesquelles on travaille sur la
manière dont il pourrait franchir un peu
la limite d'un pas avant de le retirer
ce qu'on appelle la théorie du fait
accompli en disant ah j'ai juste fait ça
mais on arrête je ne vous touche pas
plus et vous comprenez bien que
forcément les États-Unis rentreraient
pas en guerre frontale contre la Russie
une invasion de la Russie publique dans
ce genre de décision et bien les
opinions publiques aujourd'hui elles
dirigent quand même beaucoup y compris
même dans les autocraties enfin je veux
dire même les autocrates même sont quand
même pas mal conditionnés
contenir leurs opinions publiques à leur
mentir à leur expliquer parce que en
fait sans le peuple personne n'est rien
d'une certaine manière et ça vous avez
raison il y a un décisionnel stratégique
qui peut surtout en France par exemple
au Royaume-Uni c'est pas le cas parce
que le Parlement a un rôle
supplémentaire mais fondamentalement bon
est-ce que l'OTAN entrerait en guerre
contre la Russie pour un missile c'est
pas sûr on avait travaillé pour notre
ouvrage avec un spécial britannique qui
avait donné un exemple comme ça en
disant imaginez en parlant d'une base
que je ne vais pas citer mais imaginez
deux hélicoptères russes qui arrivent à
cet endroit là qui détruisent la basse
qui repartent juste cette base là on la
voulait pas c'était une opération de
force spéciale on n'est pas en guerre
l'OTAN rentrerait tel en guerre contre
contre la Russie et sa théorie et je le
rejoins sur ce point c'est non bon on
est au cœur de notre débat le conflit
peut-il s'étendre générale oui juste un
point sur les Britanniques qui se trouve
que c'est un sujet que je connais bien
ils ont changé complètement de position
après la guerre en Irak en fait la
guerre en Irak comme vous le savez a été
décidé par ton contre la vie des
populations et la meilleure preuve a été
qu'au moment où était prévu une attaque
en Syrie vous souvenez dans lequel les
Américains ont refusé d'un seul coup les
Britanniques sont dit on va demander au
Parlement alors qu'avant c'était pas du
tout le cas donc ça veut dire que c'est
à cause d'une faute d'un gouvernement
que la position a changé et que
maintenant il y a une position
différente ce que je veux dire sur le
dans la stratégie russe on dit
l'escalade pour provoquer la désescalade
c'est un peu ça c'est à dire on tente un
coup puis on se retire c'est là où il y
a besoin de réflexion d'analyse ça veut
pas dire que le dispositif complet mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que sur le
fond le président Poutine sait très bien
que s'il ne fait pas une escalade pour
une des escalade s'il fait une véritable
escalade il a perdu alors on l'a dit ce
missile tombé c'est missile tombait en
Pologne ont aussi percuté le G20 ce
rendez-vous des chefs d'État et
gouvernement qui se tenait à à Bali en
Indonésie alors je vous propose de
revoir ce que ce le
l'extrait pardon de ce communiqué commun
donc la plupart des membres du G20 à
condamné fermement la guerre en Ukraine
et tous se sont accordés sur le fait que
le conflit sape l'économie mondiale donc
on a ce texte et puis on a très vite
après un président français qui pratique
un petit peu la méthode Coué pour
Emmanuel Macron le message envoyé à la
Russie est très clair écoute ce G20 à
Bali nous montre que malgré les tensions
et les risques de division le
multilatéralisme et la défense de la
paix continue de prévaloir
car c'est l'intérêt de tous
la Russie n'a pas souhaité s'isoler face
à une majorité de fêtes au G20 sur ce
point et au-delà des négociations
pendant ces deux jours de sommet et dans
les jours qui ont précédé au niveau de
nos chers pas la Russie doit désormais
entendre le message qui lui a été très
clairement envoyé par la communauté
internationale ici réunie
et revenir à la table des négociations
alors
dans cette fin d'après-midi voilà on va
d'un urgent de la FP à l'autre puisque
après la déclaration de volody
mirzelinski qui répétait le missile
tombé en Pologne était russe ça nous
vient de Washington rien ne contredit la
thèse selon laquelle le missile tombait
en Pologne provient de la défense
ukrainienne communiquée de la Maison
Blanche voilà ça va certainement animer
les prochaines heures pendant et les
prochains jours voilà il va il va et on
l'a déjà évoqué dans ce débat donc on va
pas y revenir mais ça va poser une
question sur la communication de
l'Ukraine et de son président dans les
prochaines heures
du président qui cite la Russie qui n'a
pas voulu s'isoler face aux multiples
très intéressant de savoir que c'était
serré de la broche qui était envoyé
lavrof pendant 7 ans ambassadeur de la
Russie
aux Nations Unies je l'ai bien connu
donc le multilatéralisme si vous voulez
c'est quelque chose qui connaît donc il
a du bien voir que il y a un moment où
être dans le coin ça va pas trop donc il
va falloir
accepter un certain nombre de termes si
on veut pas être tout seul face au reste
du monde maintenant évidemment comme
vous le disiez le président pratique la
méthode cohérent les Russes ne pouvaient
pas admettre que la Russie soit
condamnée elle-même donc il pouvait pas
signer ça mais du coup ils ont signé
tout le reste mais alors dans je sais
pas si vous l'avez écouté dans dans son
intégralité la prise de parole de
d'Emmanuel Macron mais un message clair
c'est cette formule elle est revenue je
crois une dizaine de fois dans le
discours je viens interrompre est-ce que
c'est aussi clair que ça notamment à
destination de la Russie il a rappelé
quand même le dernier vote et d'ailleurs
qu'on pourrait accroître avec d'autres
votes de l'assemblée générale des
Nations unies qui sont des messages
extrêmement clairs effectivement
c'est c'est un message clair même si la
Russie derrière nous explique oui mais
en fait dans ce texte il est aussi
reconnu que c'est l'Occident qui a
provoqué la guerre genre autre chose qui
est une interprétation complètement
US que du texte c'est à dire que c'est
le mieux que le mieux je me dis mais que
l'on pouvait obtenir avec un
représentant russe autour de la table
quoi c'est c'est ça non non c'était le
mieux qu'on pouvait obtenir avec les
représentants du G20 avec d'autres
représentants d'État classique
et vous savez
l'unanimité
fondamentale de principe sur le droit
international tel que on la connaît ici
elle est pas forcément partagée partout
dans le monde en réalité
pas que certains états soutiennent
ouvertement la Russie dans sa
garde-agression contre contre l'Ukraine
il y en a très peu il y a l’érythrée la
Corée du Nord la Syrie entre guillemets
c'est à dire le régime de Bachar
al-Assad et la Biélorussie ça fait quand
même pas ni une communauté
internationale et en termes de de régime
politique on est quand même plutôt dans
le trait dur mais en revanche il y a
beaucoup d'États soit qui s'en fiche
soit qu'on décidait pour des intérêts
économiques voire stratégique par
exemple en termes d'armement d'accepter
un certain nombre de choses c'est le cas
par exemple de l'Inde même de la Turquie
d'une certaine manière qui considère
qu'elle a une position d'équilibre du
Mali qui est soutenu par les compagnies
Wagner ou alors d'État qui sont pas des
États démocratiques y compris même au
sein des populations civiles il y a des
messages parce que nous on a interdit
vous voyez un château des Spoutnik mais
non seulement il continue d'émettre par
internet mais en plus ils ont des
émissions multiningues et s'adressent à
tout un tas de de peuples dans mon
entier et le nouveau message de Moscou
c'est regarder les Occidentaux la
démocratie c'est tellement mauvais en
fait c'est un outil de domination contre
vous c'est une chose culturelle la
démocratie ne serait pas un système
théorique où les gens décident pour leur
dirigeants ce serait un outil de
domination de l'accident donc il
culturalise en réalité je reviens sur le
le l'avenir enfin vous la stratégie ou
les mois à venir dans ce conflit en
Ukraine puisque dans la déclaration
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a cette idée de
de négociation d'amener Vladimir Poutine
à la table des négociations Irina
mitrychinent vu du crâne est-ce qu'on
croit que ce sont des négociations qui
peuvent mettre fin à cette guerre
on n'en voit pas les indices qui
pourraient donc faire croire que que ça
serait possible et le manuel Macron a
dit que le message était très clair mais
dans toute la question de savoir est-ce
que la Russie l'a bien reçu a compris il
va agir en conséquence et je ne pense
pas que ça sera le cas donc est-ce que
ça va pas rester vos pieux c'est donc ça
veut dire que la porte de la négociation
est pas fermée mais que dans l'esprit de
du pouvoir ukrainien c'est la victoire
qui mettra fin à la guerre c'est on peut
mettre ces mots-là d'une part c'est avec
toi qui mettra fin la guerre d'autre
part les économies croit absolument pas
en la bonne foi des Russes c'est à dire
qu'il pense que les Russes aujourd'hui
veulent demande la négociation pour
avoir une pause pour pouvoir refaire
leur armement réarmer mobiliser leur
armée etc et reprendre la guerre de plus
belle c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé en 2015 après le minisque 2 les
Russie a juste attendu X années en
pensant qu'il y avait une bonne fenêtre
de tir et là ré-attaquer l'Ukraine
puisqu'il l'objectif est de récupérer
toute l'Ukraine Dominique trinquant pour
pour accepter de négocier
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait à venir Poutine
c'est-à-dire il faut qu'il puisse sortir
par le haut
il faudrait une même une petite victoire
militaire comment on peut imaginer ça
non écoutez compte tenues des positions
respectives du crâne et de la Russie
je pense que il y a une option qui est
la défaite militaire qui amène un
changement à la tête du Kremlin
aujourd'hui comment Poutine peut-il
revenir en arrière enfin toute
l'histoire qu'on fait autour de Poutine
montre qu'il est incapable de revenir en
arrière donc
voilà et et quand aujourd'hui sur le
terrain si vous voulez on a l'impression
qu'il y a un commandant militaire celui
qui est sur le terrain qui a réussi à
obtenir du président Poutine de
décrocher de Carson donc c'est une
nouvelle stratégie ça il faut ça passe
pas inaperçu je concentre mes efforts
sur quoi sur la défense de la Crimée sur
le don-basse il y a des petites
progressions russes dans le bombasse
depuis 48 heures ah oui enfin par contre
c'est Wagner c'est un petit peu un cas
particulier mais disons que le
commandant d'opération sur le terrain
lui mène sa guerre en revanche
stratégiquement le président Poutine je
suis tout à fait d'accord le reste du
monde je discute beaucoup avec des
Africains il nous dit c'est pas notre
guerre nous attendez c'est votre truc
nous qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
aille faire là-dedans donc on reste
neutre et ça ça intéresse beaucoup le
président Poutine parce qu'il peut
enfoncer des coins contre l'Occident et
c'est sa fameuse guerre contre
l'Occident qui dépasse de beaucoup le
combat en Ukraine un dernier mot Julien
Theron on dit souvent mais c'est
peut-être une erreur d'ailleurs que que
l'hiver va geler la guerre c'est vrai
c'est pas vrai ça va la ralentir ça va
la ralentir pour par la force des choses
parce que les matériels souffrent et de
ce point de vue là c'est assez
intéressant de se dire vous allez me
dire les Russes sont quand même habitués
à des univers quand même très difficile
ils ont même renforcé leur force polaire
par exemple mais je doute qu'il est
démobilise du Grand Nord pour les
amenants Ukraine parce que
elles ne sont pas là par hasard elle
sécurise un certain de gisements en
revanche les Ukrainiens sont équipés par
les Américains par les Canadiens
également et c'est assez intéressant
parce que ce sont des vrais équipements
ce que je veux dire c'est que du point
de vue russe il y a des chaînes
logistiques qui posent beaucoup de
problèmes notamment à cause de la
corruption ou de ligne efficacité du
régime mais donc on a vu déjà tant
d'images de ces soldats qui n'ont même
pas une veste réglementaire un gilet
pare-balle ou même des Rangers quoi et
en fait vous imaginez ce que ça doit
être vous avez été conscrit vous n'avez
pas envie d'y aller vous vous retrouvez
là avec les problèmes de communication
d'orientation d'ordre avec
quelque chose qui vous tombe du ciel
avec aucune autonomie tactique genre de
choses et en plus si on vous livre pas
le matériel pour l'hiver vous imaginez
comme ça va être simple pour eux tout
dernier mot rapide conclusion un des
Ukrainiens disaient ça va être un
problème de chaussettes mouillée et de
bottes
les munitions pour la
la Corée du Nord qui est en train de
coudre les vêtements pour la rue les
vêtements les uniformes qui ont disparu
donc il y a les Britanniques du côté
ukrainien et la Corée du Nord merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces informations et
pour vous analyses respectives j'ai
interrompre je rappelle le titre de
votre livre coécrit avec Isabelle
mandreau Poutine la stratégie du
désordre jusqu'à la guerre et c'est
publié aux éditions Tallandier voilà